[Music]  you're gloria steinem  gloria gloria gloria gloria i am  i want to write about the women's  movement  [Music]  well all the magazine people said don't  do a lesbian story in the first issue  so i feel like we need to do a lesbian  story gloria steinem should rot in hell  you can't associate yourself with those  crazy women i am one of those crazy  winners  can we change the world  how did you get the name mankiller i  earned it you earned it  we gotta stop sucking and begin to buy  it  [Applause]  this is the year of women's liberation  you avoid conflict my dolly  conflict will seek you out  [Music]  the truth will set you free  but first it will piss you off  and we'll do it a thousand times again  [Music]  you